400 millions c'est le nombre de doses
prévues à produire en 2022 de ce vaccin
espagnol et cellule laboratoire hypra
qui travaillent sur ce vaccin
cette entreprise familiale située dans
la province de gérone et spécialisée
dans les vaccins sur les animaux depuis
les années 70 mais depuis la pandémie
elle s'est proposé de collaborer elle a
notamment déjà sorti un test sérologique
et travaille donc actuellement sur le
vaccin depuis un an
lors d'une visite sur place le premier
ministre espagnol pedro sanchez a
déclaré que l'espagne encourager ce
projet très prometteur
alors l'équipe de recherche indique que
les premiers résultats sont très
satisfaisants
les essais cliniques si tout va bien
devrait débuter en juin sur l'homme
alors les essais se dérouleront à
barcelone à gérone mais aussi dans
d'autres villes d'espagne
l'objectif est de voir quelle dose
fonctionne le mieux au niveau des
anticorps et si tout va bien la
production débutera en octobre
si toutes les autorités compétentes
valide ce vaccin alors pour l'espagne
qui a subi de plein fouet la crise
sanitaire et la crise économique qui en
découlent
ce projet de vaccin est donc une lueur
d'espoir